alors vous avez tous des questions et je
vous dis ce que vous allez voir dans
cette interview c'est complètement
dingue on a halluciné avec la production
vraiment des révélations qui a pu faire
nous qui a pu nous faire le procurant
déjà merci à lui vraiment d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'avoir
répondu positivement à notre demande
d'interview
valérie bénaïm vous avez posé une
question oui aux procureurs qu'elle
était première question qu'ils avaient
qui avait-il dans l'ordinateur de
christian quesada et il nous a répondu
le cnar d'erreur de la république déjà
première question en vol et nous a
répondu à cette question
regarde selon les enquêteurs c'est
plusieurs milliers de l'image qu'ils ont
été répertoriés sont pas tous de la même
gravité mais il ya des images clairement
ce sont des viols d'enfants de moins de
dix ans qui sont photographiés et qui
sont ensuite diffusés à des personnes
qui se complaisent devant le vent ce
type d'image alors voilà il les a
répondu donc il y à bien
donc dans son ordinateur ce genre de
vidéos comme il vient d'en parler gilles
où vous le saviez alors oui c'est une
j'ai appris grâce à l'interview mais
c'est une cellule spécifique spécialisés
de la gendarmerie de lyon qui s'occupe
de l'enquète ils veulent aussi savoir
s'il ya eu d'autres mineurs qui auraient
été c'est leur terme harponné par
christian quesada pour voir s'il est
fait pour être encore plus grave et
surtout ils se sont aperçus que
christian quesada a mis longtemps à être
repérés parce que ils avaient réussi à
utiliser des adresses fictives qui
n'était pas à son nom qu'il bloquait au
fur et à mesure donc ils ont mis très
longtemps à forcer les portes d'entrée
l'ordinateur donc et préméditation
jean michel maire vous avez posé une
question en question au procureur
oui ce cri tition quesada pour sa
défense a avoué tout de suite aux
enquêteurs qu'il est étonné qu'ils
diffusaient des images
pédopornographiques mais au dessus du
dic n'était jamais passé à l'acte pour
jouer savoir s'il procure à des
informations sur ceux sur ce passage
direct ou par votre question c'était
christian quesada et il passe à la
rivière passe à l'acte et il a répondu
également assez compliqué répondu à
toutes nos questions certes fonctions
pour l'instant il n'est pas mise en
examen
pour des faits d'agressions de viol sont
les majors sur les mineurs donc
juridiquement le
magistrat instructeur et les enquêteurs
ne travaille pas sur ces hypothèses
si au cours des investigations destinées
à identifier les personnes avec qui il a
une antenne changer de fichiers etc
on m'apprend qu'éventuellement il ya pu
avoir